A very disturbing image of some notes that
Donald Trump wrote for himself before speaking
to the press yesterday has been leaked. And
it's bizarre and strange in all of the most
unusual ways. This was Trump. Uh, this was,
these were Trump's notes before. Briefly speaking
to reporters before heading out to Texas yesterday.
This was one of those black Sharpie notes
that Donald Trump does seemingly moving to
a very, very large Sharpie at this point,
and it really signals something very off with
his ability to think. Let's take a look at
the picture. It reads, I want nothing. I want
nothing twice. I want no quid. Pro quo tells
the Lynskey ends. It's the president's last
name. Zelenskyi is totally misspelled. Trump
has no idea how to spell. It tells Alinsky
to do the right thing.
This is how you know it's really Trump's notes
because he misspelled Zelinsky his name. This
is the final word from the president of the
U S I actually don't know what's weirder that
Trump thought this was a solid way to push
back against the impeachment hearing claims
made yesterday by Gordon songland or that
Trump needed notes to remember this. The fact
that a president would need these notes to
say basically I didn't do anything wrong is
weird. I could understand if Donald Trump
had very specific details or facts, times,
dates, places, people's names who are difficult
to pronounce. Something written down would
make sense for that, but this is just, I didn't
do anything wrong. This is extraordinarily
childish, but it also again corroborates the
idea that Trump can barely remember anything.
It corroborates the allegations we've been
hearing about Trump's memory. He can't remember
saying things. He can't remember being told
things here now is how it all shook out in
video form. Once again, totally unhinged.
Last second press conference with the chopper
going in the background. Here's how Donald
Trump used those notes.
What do you want from you brain? I keep hearing
all these different ideas that there is. Why
do you want, why do you want, it was a very
short and abrupt congregations that he had
with me. They said he was not in a good mood.
I'm always in a good mood. I don't know what
that is. He just said, now he's talking about
what my response, Joe, he's going, why do
you want, what do you want to hear? All these
series? What do you want? Right? And now here's
my response that he gave you guys. Kay. Ready?
You have the cameras rolling? I want nothing.
That's what I want from you, Greg. That's
what I saw. I want nothing. I said it twice.
So he goes, he asked me the question, what
do you want? I keep hearing all these things.
What do you want?
He finally gets me. I don't know him very
well. I have not spoken to him much. This
is not a man I know. Well seems like a nice
guy though. But I don't know him. Well, he
was with other candidates. He actually supported
other candidates. Not me. Payment late. But
here's my response. Now, if you were in fake
news, you'd cover it properly. I say to the
ambassador, I did respond. I want nothing.
I want nothing. I want no quid. Pro quo tells
Joe Lynskey, president Zelinsky to do the
right thing. So here's my answer. I want nothing.
I want nothing.
Even if you don't think this guy needs to
be removed immediately. How could tens of
millions of people think that this is an even
remotely well-suited person for the presidency?
Like how is when we get used to it because
we have scandal fatigue and insanity, fatigue
and delusional fatigue. You know we have all
the fatigue from everything that's going on,
but how is it possible that tens of millions
of people thought voting for this guy was
a good idea? So listen, if Trump literally
said, here's why this, this doesn't make any
sense. If Trump got on the phone with Sunland
and said, listen, I want no quid pro quo,
why is he even talking about a quid pro quo?
Why is that term being used? It's like calling
your wife and saying, Hey, listen, could you
grab some chicken thighs and Greek yogurt,
bananas, granny Smith, Apple, the only Apple
worth anything by the way, ice cream and listen,
I don't want any shoplifting of these items
from the grocery store.
Okay, no stealing of this stuff at all. Just
buy this stuff. Pay for it. Okay. It would
be very weird to bring that up unprovoked,
and of course the answer is Trump didn't bring
it up on provoke because the day this conversation
happened, news had broken and Donald Trump
had reason to get on the record with Sundland
at least in some way that he doesn't want
to do anything. No quid pro quo, none of this
stuff. If it wasn't tied to that, it would
be very weird to bring up that you don't want
a quid pro quo. The fact that he brought it
up at all, it makes us question the timing
and the timing. Of course, it tells us exactly
why it is that Donald Trump brought it up.
It's Trump is actually citing it as a defense.
It's more incriminating that Donald Trump
felt the need to get on the phone and say
these things.
I think Nancy Pelosi had it right when she
said, Trump is simply in way over his head
here and notice that every supposedly exculpatory
data point or document that is released by
the Trump administration is actually more
incriminating. The Zelenskyi July 25 phone
call, Trump says, you know what? Let's release
a truncated transcript of a part of it. It's
released and it's more incriminating. Despite
Donald Trump citing it as exonerating. Uh,
he says, Oh, Gordon Sunland recalled that
on this particular phone call. I said, no
quid pro quo despite testifying that it was
a quid pro quo. Let me just go out there and
repeat that. Hey, I got right on the phone
with this guy and told him, I don't want a
quid pro quo. Why would anyone talk about
a quid pro quo if there was no quid pro quo
going on? They don't realize it is all further
incriminating and whether there will be any
consequences is a different question, which
I'll address at the top of tomorrow's show
on the Friday show,